president Trump's lawyer Rudy Giuliani
says the president reimbursed attorney
Michael Cohen for a non-disclosure
agreement with adult film star stormy
Daniels Daniel's alleges she had sex
with mr. Trump back in 2006 which the
president denies Cohen paid her 130
thousand dollars to keep quiet 11 days
before the election this morning
President Trump tweeted Cohen quote
received a monthly retainer not from the
campaign he added money from the
campaign or campaign contributions
played no role in this transaction
Giuliani told Fox News the president's
repayment was lawful that money was not
campaign money sorry I'm giving you a
fact now that you don't know it's not
campaign money no campaign finance
violation so they funneled it through
the law firm funneled through law firm
and the president repaid it oh I didn't
know that he did yeah there's no
campaign finance law zero later Giuliani
told The Washington Post mr. Trump
learned most of the details of the
payment after the FBI raided Cohen last
month he said the president was not
aware of the payment when it was made
but Cohen knew he would be reimbursed
because of his arrangement with the
president Michael avenatti stormy
Daniels attorney joins us now at the
table to discuss what did you think when
you first thought you know the White
House people in the White House last
night were saying they were stunned to
hear Rudy Giuliani say what he said last
night on Fox what do you think well I
was equally stunned and I was speechless
because now we have a clear example of
the president and Michael Cohen aligned
repeatedly to the American people Gail
about this payment about the arrangement
the agreement the agreement what the
president knew and when he knew it and I
think we've only scratched the surface
and I think the more we dig the more
untoward conduct we're going to find it
how does this affect your case Michael
wow it makes our case that much stronger
and I think it makes our efforts to
depose the president that much stronger
and much opposed and that much go ahead
good and that much more likely that we
are going to depose the president for
this reason Gail because the stories
keep changing with each passing
week more information comes out and much
of it is very inconsistent it's time
that people are forced to raise their
right hand and testify under oath
exactly what happened and by that I'm
not talking about on Fox and Friends but
you've always said that he wasn't
telling the truth about what happened
between the two of them and so now it's
been clear that he has paid the money
Rudy Giuliani has admitted that we still
don't know why he paid the money though
I think that that's a very interesting
little detail you think do you think
Rudy Giuliani is is accurate when he
says the President did not know what his
deal happened and that the money was
paid after absolutely not I don't think
that's accurate at all and now what now
what mr. Trump and mr. Cohen and now mr.
Giuliani expect the American people to
believe as his follows that a woman came
forward a adult film star made up a
story about having sex with the
president they didn't believe her they
knew she was lying and they promptly
paid her 130 thousand dollars it's
absurd these guys are these guys are
making it up as they go along they're
not looking at the big picture they're
not telling the truth and ultimately
it's going to cost them dearly well as
you know the president has been tweeting
this morning and he said that the
agreement with Miss Daniels was made to
stop the false and extortionist
accusations made by her about an affair
you currently have an anti defamation
lawsuit against the president is this
going to be added to that lawsuit these
equipment we haven't made a definitive
decision because this just happened but
I think it's very very likely you say
your client lied the president is
digging his hole a hole deeper and
deeper with each passing day now we have
mr. Giuliani this morning on Fox and
Friends doing the same you know look I
hope they keep talking and I hope they
keep tweeting because our case just
keeps getting me but the president won't
serve out his term in office how's he
gonna resign I believe that ultimately
he will be forced to resign due to
information that his is going to come to
light in connection with our case as
well as the raids by the FBI this is a
very what is it Michael that you now
expect to prove that we don't already
know I think we're going to prove the
details of this reimbursement I think
there's going to likely be criminal
liability criminal exposure in
connection with how this payment was
handled how the money in what sense how
the money flowed if they were if they
were sending bogus
Law Firm retainer invoices in an effort
to have those paid with the expectation
that no work was going to be performed
and that's how they were going to
reimburse the this payment that very
well may have significant liability
associated with it and again I think
we've only scratched the surface I think
this is one deal that one untoward deal
of many that's going to come to light in
connection with those raids Giuliani
says this is not campaign money whether
it's campaign money or not that's not
the measure of whether campaign finance
violations occurred there's an the
campaign finance law is multifaceted
there's a number of things you can and
cannot do I think it's clear that if an
effort was made to avoid reporting this
whether it be by Michael Cohen or by the
President himself
or by his organization that's ultimately
going to prove to be very problematic
what is stormy Daniels saying this
morning what is your client saying about
all this well with each passing day she
feels more and more vindicated because
the predictions that we've made in this
case over the last two months continue
to come true what we've told the
American people ultimately what we were
going to show continues to come true and
anyone that disputes that can go back
and look what we've said over the last
two months compared to what the
president and Michael Cohen have spent
like 11 a day thanks for coming into
being thank you this morning we
appreciate it